i like want to check myself for being
all like philosophical or whatever
because like [ __ ] this kid man like
i i just hate that
anyone is like
you know
respects this in any way
well he doesn't [ __ ] care about
boxing like that's what i was just
thinking that like
sorry go ahead i just i just feel like
what frustrates me about the whole event
is
it to me it's like it just mocks
like the institutions of things and like
the point of being committed to
something and like
the people who actually do care about
boxing like the dude love like two or
three fights before
um i forget his first name
uh he fought the kid who looked like
steve will do it did you watch that no i
didn't i didn't watch any of it oh and i
also did not buy it
i i definitely did not buy it
oh you did
tommy fury was fighting yeah that's true
i kind of looked at it as like you're
kind of supporting the other fighters
yeah you know
anyway
tommy fury looked like [ __ ] in there oh
my god he looks so horrible him and jake
should fight because they both look so
confused with their own bodies
yeah
tommy looks like he is like not
totally used to the steroids
that he's yeah or the length of his arms
like he's gigantic yeah like just
picture that guy his arms are like
unnaturally [ __ ] huge yeah i think he
like ballooned he took something
and like in one year has doubled in size
and he's like not used to his like new
surface area yeah he took the he took
the arm steroids that make them longer
not thicker no no but they're thick as
[ __ ] too yeah but you know he already
had the thick yeah so his his training
camp they thought oh we'll lengthen you
can you bring a picture of him
tommy fury
and you took the lengthening steroids
to be fair like
you know he might he might have just
been like jet-lagged nervous whatever
he was fighting a dude like seven inches
shorter than him as well yeah everyone
is being critical saying like dude
you're fighting a like a 155 or you
should be putting him in the dirt and
searching searching on twitter because
there's a good meme
about like him and tyson being the same
gene pool
and having like opposite bodies
but
yeah him and jake should fight
tommy had this thing he's like oh i i
i approached jake after the fight with
no security or just the two of us and i
could tell there was nothing in his soul
and i was like maybe because he was
tired though yeah
i'll give jake that he probably was
tired from getting clapped in the face
yeah
there look at that picture
click on that click on that picture so
we can see it
look at his [ __ ] arms yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah it looks like he's wearing one of
the
suits that we have yeah serious
i mean he's he's like uh he's how you
would create yourself in a wrestling
game yeah yeah just put all the points
on biceps yeah and shoulders yeah
and he look
he looks like inflated like he doesn't
even look like a real human yeah
yeah he was
he was not looking super sharp in there
yeah so like you were saying
the whole the whole point like in order
to drive ticket sales
and to
you know not be laughed at or whatever
he was like
preaching constantly preaching and
repeating the message that he's taking
this seriously yeah he's boxing his ass
off he wants to like be good at this
sport and like give respect to the sport
he wants to help the sport and then like
two matches in one year and he's like
i'm [ __ ] done yeah i i came here i
just rinsed the money out of this i just
yeah oh just
[ __ ] coins pouring out yeah and i'm
just gonna leave it in the [ __ ] dirt
yeah you know
and that that's where now he's gonna
move on to nfts or something next and
all his campaigns about like fighter pay
and this and that it's it's how is
anyone this stupid to like buy any of it
you know
it it's like tyron said tyron's like he
wants to play the heel and then he he
plants all these seeds then he wants a
pat on the back after he goes in there
and gets kind of like walked down and
and
you know
he he might have had like more combos
here and there but
he he was running away yeah and that
that man was scared and for all that
[ __ ] hurrah he puts on that's where i
feel comfortable just like bagging on
him because
you're gonna sit there and chirp like
you're the like you're the big man like
you're the tough guy you gotta walk down
that whole fight
you almost got your [ __ ] canned
know i think i think he knows
whoever his next opponent has to be has
to be dog [ __ ]
because he
even a a debut boxing match like that
like he wasn't ready yeah
big ass breaths after round two
you breathing deep
real deep
anyone like can you imagine doing anyone
just a bit more fluid
touching up like
like body shots and stuff i'd be a rap
the other thing that was really
interesting that i did like about this
is
so he beat ben and he beat um
uh what's his name basketball player
nate robinson but both of those were so
quick that he never had to be a boxer
yeah so actually what i liked about this
going the full eight is now whoever goes
at him next
they get to see his full [ __ ]
performance yeah you get to see every
aspect of his game yeah but it's not
going to happen because he's retired
yeah
yeah there's no point of even harping on
this anymore yep he's literally i'm
saying he's going to go on to the next
thing no yeah he's never going to make
50 million bucks in
one month and then he's going to move on
the next thing
and then
that's like the problem it's just like
i don't know like
i mean
i don't i just hate that i don't know
well i hate that because they're doing
it with crypto now yeah like they're
back at it logan's back at it he's
coming out with it he sees the crypto
punk thing he sees the um board eight
yacht club thing and he's like i gotta
do my own i have to i have to cash in on
this like i'd be stupid not to so now
he's doing some nft game and i don't
know if it's legit or not i have no idea
but i sent this
because i was looking into this to like
that you know secondary market on the
original nft
which in the first nft boom you know
that was what like two months ago or
something like that three months ago
maybe longer
but like when everyone was tweeting
about nfts nfcs nfts and he was like i
gotta get in on this and he did and he
made like five million bucks right yep
selling these things for one ethereum
each which at the time was like 1500
bucks i think right now they're going to
scroll down
they're going for
0.14 0.1 and there's like five being
traded every day so ten percent of their
original value aka and there's no market
for it yeah so there's he sold like what
ten thousand of these or maybe more yeah
ten thousand of these at like a thousand
to fifteen hundred bucks per pop yeah
and
all that's just waste that's just money
that his fans just gave to him
that's that's the part that's crazy is
these dudes just scam their audience
like left and right
and
somehow like
somehow people you know i mean obviously
it's business so in business people
don't care about [ __ ] like this but even
showtime
i'm i was thinking
who cares that he brings the fighters
their biggest payday yet because their
fighters won't get a bigger payday after
that like him parading around that he
cares about like fighter pay and stuff
is not even a band-aid it's like a
one-time solve he's not like actually
changing anything in the institution of
fighting
and and
so i feel like that's that shouldn't
even afford him credibility and more
than that
why is showtime even lending their name
to this [ __ ] [ __ ] like someone
behind the scenes has to know like yo
this dude is going to partner with us
big up his name and then quit on us the
same way they've done it with nfts and
everything else so why the [ __ ] do
people keep partnering with these dudes
and like giving them a spot
and that's funny that's all it's about i
know but that's the part that pisses me
off it's just like not one person that
goes
not [ __ ] that man we just we just can't
it doesn't matter like
because
i don't know yeah it is all money was
done also um
the dink dink doing that was gonna bring
another yeah ding dong what's up with
that it's in the dirt yeah completely
yep they they their website's down they
banded it
so it's like i think to them it's like
these are exp experiments or just like
you know iterating fast but like in a
classic startup business sense where
like fast iteration is necessary to like
find product market fit yeah you don't
it's not at the expense of other people
yeah all this [ __ ] is
at the expense of people who are putting
money into these projects and then
losing it yep
well you know what it is man it's all
kids
and it's like the parents just don't get
who these kids are you know
the last thing i'll say that really got
on my [ __ ] nerves was
when
jake paul's like oh like to the kids i'm
like mike tyson
right
and the sad part is is that is true
but the part that doesn't resonate with
people is
or at least like with mike tyson when
that dude was coming up he was a star
and he was special because he was good
at what he did yeah
and that's how he like it used to be you
had to be pretty good like good at what
you
it'd be pretty goo at what you do
you know like think about any great
athlete anyone who's an icon they're
good at what they do and the thing that
jake is good at is scamming
yeah like he's not a good boxer
he's decent but he's not a great he's
not mike tyson he's not [ __ ] like
17-0 at you know 19 or whatever you know
coming back from with a crazy like
comeback story as a human being he's a
dude who knocked out a [ __ ] guy off a
hip replacement surgery
and a retired basketball player yeah
yeah i think like you know we were
talking about david arquette we're
talking about um bo burnham
and you know how much energy and effort
and dedication they put into one thing
not knowing for sure whether or not it
was going to work right yeah that is you
know on the one side of the scale where
it's like people
really appreciate that stuff and it
doesn't always work out yeah right for
them it did
but then there's a polar opposite side
of the scale where it's like
you know they're like wait i can make
how much money for not doing that much
yep okay let's do it and you could call
that smart
but it doesn't command respect and i
think they get really mad when people
don't respect them like his constant
narrative was like
respect me as a fighter i'm a fighter
and no nobody was like no but then you
know he does it one time and then he
just stops yeah and it's like well this
is the kind of [ __ ] that doesn't command
respect is yeah you don't respect yeah
back it it's it's so annoying man and
i just like i don't get it i don't get
how you're a fan of a person like this
if you're older than 12
which is probably a lot of the you know
that's all it is that's all it's ever
been yeah
you know 12 year old kids around the
world i guess fortnite and anything that
you feel like you can't understand is 12
year old kids fortnite jake paul